[Musique]
si
bien euh d'habitude je ne sortirais pas un
lundi
euh et c'est pourquoi je suis ici et je pensais que
nous faisions le déjeuner puis le
souper ce soir
et nous le ferons tous les jours maintenant
chaque lundi mardi mercredi
et ouais c'est juste une belle incitation à
sortir et à aller manger au restaurant actuellement je pense que
dans la situation où les gens
sont à la maison en congé comme moi je
pense que c'est bien de sortir et de faire un
peu pour la communauté que vous connaissez
le gouvernement redonner nous et je
pense que c'est génial que nous redonnions
aux gens qui en ont beaucoup besoin
je veux dire que je déteste voir ce restaurant
fermer des restaurants aussi incroyables à Londres
et vous les voyez le fermer c'est affreux
donc
quoi qu'ils fassent j'espère que ça marche
parce que j'aimerais revoir ces
restaurants
[Music]
[Applaudissements]
toi